neben dem kampf gegen das corona virus
gibt es ein weiteres riesiges problem
derzeit die ganzen falschmeldung die es
zu diesem thema gibt und diese fake news
haben fatale folgen doch wir alle können
selbst etwas aktiv dagegen tun klingt
zum science fiction hier gibt es
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocken und dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen es sind unzählige gerüchte
die in zeiten der kroner krise die runde
machen und zwar nicht nur bei whatsapp
sondern in allen sozialen netzwerken
dabei geht es zum beispiel darum dass
die supermärkte nur noch stundenweise
öffnen aber auch dass die medikamente
knapp sind am wochenende wurde eine
sprachnachricht über whatsapp verbreitet
in der eine angebliche mitarbeiterin der
supermarktkette aldi süd zu
hamsterkäufen aufrief sie warnte
eindringlich davor dass die märkte kurz
davor wären zu schließen aldi süd gab
dann in einer facebook botschaft bekannt
dass die filialen selbstverständlich für
alle geöffnet bleiben zitat um euch
produkte des täglichen bedarfs anbieten
zu können dann das nächste gerücht nach
dem das medikament ibuprofen das risiko
erhöhe sich mit corona anzustecken das
wiener uni klinikum wurde als quelle
genannt doch die einrichtung stellte
schnell klar dass es sich eindeutig um
fake news handelt dazu heißt es bei
twitter von der uni wien achtung bei den
derzeit kursierenden whatsapp text und
sprachnachrichten rund um angebliche
forschungsergebnisse der wiener
uniklinik zu einem zusammenhang zwischen
ibuprofen und cupid 19 handelt es sich
um fake news die in keinerlei verbindung
mit der meduni wien stehen wenn man
jedoch dass corona virus in sich trägt
sollte man nicht ohne ärztlichen rat
ibuprofen nehmen laut der
weltgesundheitsorganisation who gibt es
zwar keine neuen studien aus denen
hervorgeht dass ibuprofen mit einer
höheren sterblichkeit verbunden ist
dennoch wird die genaue lage derzeit
noch eingehend geprüft laut einem
sprecher ist die einnahme von
paracetamol im verdachtsfall angeraten
feststehen aber auch umgekehrte
behauptungen wie beispielsweise dass
ibuprofen gegen das virus helfer sind
definitiv falsch die gerüchteküche
brodelt jedenfalls und die folgen sind
fatal
große teile der bevölkerung
sind verängstigt und man sieht es in den
teils leer gekauften supermärkten dass
die hamsterkäufe überhandgenommen habe
der ansturm ist auch wegen der vielen
fake news so groß dass die supermärkte
beispielsweise toilettenpapier händisch
verteilen und zwar nur eine packung pro
haushalt die politik dagegen versichert
dass es keine versorgungsengpässe gibt
und ruft dazu auf hamsterkäufe zu
vermeiden fun fact in einem bericht habe
ich den schwenk über ein leer gekauft
das regal gesehen nehmen ist halt kein
gruppe b mehr gab da standen aber noch
küchenrollen kleiner tipp unter einer
küchenrolle kann man mit einem
brotmesser drei klopapierrollen
schneiden
oh man also klar ist jedenfalls fake
news bringen uns nicht weiter ganz im
gegenteil doch es ist schwierig die
leute aufzuspüren die die fans in die
welt setzen und sehen dann zu belangen
doch einen fall aus österreich zeigt
dass das doch klappen kann
hier hatten sich zwei männer in
schutzanzügen fotografiert und
verbreitet dass es bei ihnen in der
gemeinde einen infektionsfall gäbe das
foto gegen dann bei facebook und
whatsapp herum und die urheber wurden
dingfest gemacht sie müssen jetzt damit
rechnen dass sie strafrechtlich belangt
werden und ich vermute mal dass die
strafen sehr bald schon sehr drakonisch
werden und damit das öffentliche leben
einigermaßen geregelt aufrechterhalten
werden kann
das hier ist nämlich kein spaß es ist
eine katastrophe und um sie
durchzustehen müssen menschen
zusammenhalten müssen wir zusammenhalten
und wir müssen uns alle wirklich
vernünftig verhalten auch in deutschland
schaltet sich jetzt die politik ein so
beispielsweise spd innenminister boris
pistorius der die bundesregierung zum
handeln aufgefordert hat in einem
spiegel interview sagt der politiker
tech news zur versorgungslage in zeiten
der korona krise sind brandgefährlich
sie können panik hamsterkäufe und
konflikte auslösen und sind daher auf
das schärfste zu verurteilen
daher müssen wir mit bußgeldern oder
sogar strafandrohungen abschrecken auch
technologieunternehmen wie google
twitter und microsoft haben jetzt
angekündigt künftig eng zusammenarbeiten
zu wollen um fehlinformationen über das
cola virus auf ihren plattformen zu
unterbinden endlich wird mal was richtig
gegen fitness getan hoffe ich zumindest
dennoch muss jede und jeder einzelne von
uns selbst darauf achten nicht auf
solche fake news hereinzufallen und
diese weiter zu verbreiten denn das ist
das problem
eine typische erscheinungsform ist
übrigens der kettenbrief in chats oft
sind diese
als persönliche erfahrungsberichte getan
formuliert wird das dann zum beispiel so
meine schwester ist ärztin china und
arbeit vor ort in einem krankenhaus von
ihr wurde mir jetzt aufgetragen die
folgenden informationen an freunde
weiterzugeben und so geht es dann los
mit den fake news vor allem bei whatsapp
sollten wir nicht auch wilde behauptung
hereinfallen und hier ist die gefahr
groß da wir unseren bekannten und
freundinnen und freunden mit denen wir
per web zu tun haben natürlich ein
gewisses vertrauen entgegenbringen doch
in dieser lage ist ein gesundes
misstrauen an geraten deswegen bitte
ganz genau hinschauen und bilder artikel
und meldungen nicht einfach teil besser
ganz genau hingucken und prüfen ob an
den inhalten etwas dran ist denn die
dynamik vom falschmeldung ist nicht zu
unterschätzen wenn sie einmal im netz
auftauchen entwickeln sie schnell eine
dynamik gegen die selbst mit gute
aufklärung kaum anzukommen ist das beste
was wir jetzt machen kann ist sich
regelmäßig die hände zu waschen zu hause
zu bleiben und sich zu informieren und
zwar dort wo es qualitätsgesicherte
informationen gibt beispielsweise beim
robert-koch-institut einen besonders
krassen fall von thesy kness den gibt's
übrigens jetzt in deutschland darüber
berichtet in diesem video über die
neuesten studien also anklicken
anschauen und klicks um science-fiction
für hintergrundinfos zu gruner und noch
viel mehr aus wissenschaft medizin und
technik abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran